bonsoir Jean-Noël barreau bonsoir merci
d'être présent ce soir vous êtes le
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications
bonsoir Mickaël Darmon comme chaque
dimanche éditorialiste i24 qui est
présent sur le côté sur le plateau
Jean-Noël baron vous étiez également sur
place un peu plus tôt en début
d'après-midi quel est le bilan que vous
faites ce soir de la situation que
s'est-il passé et quelle est la
situation la stricte point de vue
peut-être télécommunication informatique
parce qu'on sait que c'est un impact
forcément la nature des soins c'est une
cyberattaque d'ampleur qui touche
l'hôpital de Versailles Le Chesnay et
c'est absolument révoltant de s'en
prendre ainsi à nos établissements de
santé et donc à nos concitoyens les plus
fragiles je pense aux personnes âgées je
pense aux personnes malades je pense aux
nourrissons très précoce et je veux
saluer l'extraordinaire réactivité de
l'équipe de direction de des
responsables des systèmes d'information
qui hier ont eu les bons réflexes dans
les minutes qu'on suivi l'incident ils
ont isolé les systèmes informatiques
pour éviter la propagation à d'autres
services comme le SAMU par exemple et
qui ont très rapidement signalé
l'incident à notre agence nationale la
sécurité des services informatiques
c'est les bons réflexes à avoir qui
évitent un certain nombre de
consommables dramatiques de ce type
d'attaque dans les semaines qui suivent
je salue aussi évidemment les personnels
soignants qui ont été à pieds d'oeuvre
toute la nuit pour assurer la continuité
des soins et la prise en charge des
patients ça a été dit lors de votre
reportage des renforts sont venus à
l'hôpital pour faire en sorte que cette
continuité des soins puisse puisse avoir
lieu ensuite
une plainte a été déposée à 16h le
parquet cyber de Paris est saisi de la
faire et c'est la gendarmerie qui va
mener l'enquête et apporter des
solutions en remédiation de cette
attaque que je condamne évidemment avec
la plus grande fermeté à la fin du mois
d'août l'hôpital de Corbeil avait subi
le même type d'attaque il y avait une
demande de Ressons une revendication par
un groupe de hackers russe est-ce que là
vous avez des informations à ce qui est
revendications très clair est-ce qu'il y
a eu deux mondes de rançon concernant ce
qui s'est passé hier soir la plainte a
été déposée l'enquête commence et c'est
cela qui nous permettra de connaître si
une revendication est faite l'identité
des assaillants et la demande de rançon
éventuelle ce qui est sûr c'est que nous
avons là une attaque qui ressemble à
celle de Corbeil-Essonnes et qui nous
amène à renforcer évidemment notre notre
politique de prévention puisque c'est
évidemment ça l'essentiel évitez que ce
type d'attaque se produise depuis un an
et demi le gouvernement a déployé à
destination de 950 de nos plus grands
établissements de santé de nos
collectivités de nos administrations des
parcours de sécurité tous ces
établissements ne sont pas encore
arrivés au terme de ces parcours de
sécurité ce qu'ils l'ont fait ont pu
parer à un certain nombre des attaques
que nous avons connues ces dernières
semaines avec des départements des
grandes villes avec plus d'efficacité
après Corbeil-Essonnes avec le ministre
de la Santé nous avons annoncé un
renforcement un doublement des crédits
alloués 20 en plus des 20 millions qui
étaient prévus pour 150 hôpitaux pour
pouvoir couvrir plus d'hôpitaux parce
qu'évidemment face à ces attaques enfin
il y a évidemment des vies humaines qui
peuvent être en jeu même si ça n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui à Versailles grâce à
mobilisation du personnel alors à
distance j'accueille Patrick Pelloux le
médecin urgentiste bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous vous allez pousser un coup de
gueule aujourd'hui sur Twitter c'est
notamment grâce à votre information que
nous avons nous avons été au courant et
nous avons réagi et vous aviez ce soir
peut-être une question à poser au
ministre Jean-Noël Barrault qui est sur
le sur le plateau
merci merci pour votre invitation oui
monsieur le ministre j'ai bien entendu
ce que vous dites je pense hélas que
vous êtes déjà dépassé aussi comme on
l'est c'est pas une c'est pas un
reproche à vous-même c'est que on a
tellement de retard sur les systèmes
informatiques de l'hôpital ça tombe
tellement en rade régulièrement et on a
des des audits qui ont été faits
montrant que nous avons des failles de
partout ce qui se passe là pour moi
c'est une véritable attaque du pays
alors vous mettez les précautions
d'usage concernant le fait que vous ne
faites pas si c'est les Russes je peux
vous donner tout de suite la raison la
réponse on va s'apercevoir très vite que
ce sont en effet les Russes qui ont à
nouveau ses vies comme ils l'ont fait à
l'hôpital de Corbeil puisque c'est le
même mode d'action moi je pense que
vraiment si vous faites une cellule de
crise il faut que l'armée soit avec nous
je pèse mes mots je sais que ça une
composante importante mais pour moi ce
qui est en train de se passer quand vous
dites ça ne remet pas en cause
la vie des gens je voudrais juste que
vous imaginiez les conséquences que ça a
eu sur la paralysie de l'hôpital de
Corbeil ça a paralysé tout le groupement
de territoires des centaines des
milliers un million de personnes là on
déstabilise ils sont très forts les
terroristes ils déstabilise tout un
territoire de santé donc là on a envoyé
du matériel par le Samu de Paris qui
s'est mobilisé on a envoyé du matériel
pour maintenir les malades qu'on pouvait
encore maintenir dans l'hôpital il y en
a déjà évacué la situation est vraiment
terrible
Patrick Pelou je voudrais juste la
réponse de Jean-Noël Barraud et Michel
Darmon aussi qui est sur les plateaux
c'est une menace qui qui progresse qui
se développe qui se généralise qui se
professionnalisent et qui se standardise
nous avons à faire non pas
nécessairement à une attaque d'un état
contre un autre mais à de la de la
piraterie à l'exception que les les
pirates en général ont un code d'honneur
et que là ont vraiment en s'attaquant au
plus faible ainsi ça la démonstration
qu'il n'y a plus aucune morale mais ce
qui est poursuivi c'est sans doute un
gain financier ce sont des attaques qui
se systématisent et face à cela la
réponse que nous avons ce sont ces
parcours de sécurité qui commencent à
faire leurs preuves à l'hôpital Mignot
où j'étais deux fois aujourd'hui on m'a
confirmé que un certain nombre
d'attaques avaient été déjoués les
réflexes des responsables hier soir
montrent qu'il y a une prise de
conscience un à un pour voir ce qui se
passe en fait et qui ont signalé dans
les premières dans les premières minutes
montre qu'il y a une prise de conscience
et que nous arrivons mieux qu'auparavant
même s'il est conséquences sont encore
dramatiques à faire face à ces attaques
donc il y a la prévention et puis
évidemment la répression et le texte qui
vient d'être adopté la loi d'orientation
et de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur porté par Gérald Darmanin va
apporter des moyens de répression
supplémentaire et notamment des moyens
d'enquête en cas de cyberies justement
par rapport à ce que dit Monsieur Pelou
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
qu'effectivement les moyens les plus
régaliens devraient être mis en œuvre
face à cette attaque vous la qualifiez
de piraterie est-ce que ça n'est pas au
fond du terrorisme et du terrorisme
médical
je crois mais l'enquête le montrera qui
a derrière un certain nombre de ses
attaques des motifs qui ne sont pas des
motifs souverain mais qui sont des
motifs financiers c'est dramatique mais
c'est ainsi il nous faut donc agir à la
fois comme je disais sur la prévention
et sur la répression mais mais il y a
évidemment des moyens régaliens qui sont
mis qui sont mis sur la table c'est le
c'est la gendarmerie qui est chargée de
l'enquête et qui va essayer d'apporter
des solutions de remédiation et qui
éventuellement engagera des poursuites
ce qui est particulier c'est que pour la
première fois cette cyber-attaque a des
conséquences sur les patients
c'est-à-dire qu'elle est transferts de
patients est-ce que c'est à dire qu'à
partir d'aujourd'hui on doit intégrer
cette menace cette cyber menace dans la
façon dont on gère les transferts entre
passion dont on construit l'hôpital dont
on construit des systèmes informatiques
à l'hôpital parce que ce qui est plus
important j'entends bien évidemment le
plus important c'est la santé de ces
malades qui sont à l'hôpital comment
aujourd'hui on peut intégrer cette
menace au quotidien
il y a eu des transferts de patients et
en particulier de nourrissons très
précoces lors de l'attaque de l'hôpital
de Corbeil-Essonnes et je veux saluer la
très forte solidarité de l'ensemble des
établissements de santé francilien
publique et privé du Samu qui ont rendu
possible ces transferts avec des
patients très particuliers qui étaient
ces nourrissons très précoces l'hôpital
de Versailles a opéré 6 transferts à ce
stade trois adultes et trois enfants
dans un but préventif pour éviter que
d'éventuels dysfonctionnements sur les
machines ne viennent à mettre en danger
leur leur vie et leur santé donc pour
l'instant si vous voulez l'attaque n'a
pas menacé directement la sécurité des
personnes mais mais pour prévenir un
incident de ce type là des transferts
ont déjà été opérés à nouveau grâce à la
solidarité sous l'égide de l'ARS de
l'ensemble des établissements
franciliens
en votre possession est-ce que pour vous
c'est la Russie qui est
derrière ce type d'opération est-ce
qu'il faut pas craindre pour les grands
événements à venir en particulier celui
que la France prépare c'est à dire les
Jeux Olympiques 2024 la menace cyber
concerne l'ensemble de notre vie
économique et sociale désormais elle
concerne les établissements publics
comme les établissements de santé elle
concerne les entreprises une entreprise
sur deux a fait l'objet d'une tentative
d'intrusion l'année dernière elle
concerne les particuliers
sur son origine est-ce que pour vous les
Russes sont derrière
176000 demandes d'assistance par nos
concitoyens l'année dernière et ces 250
000 cette année donc ça progresse il y a
dans derrière l'essentiel de ces
attaques des groupes que qui s'apparente
à des pirates et qui sont hébergés avec
la bienveillance vraisemblablement d'un
certain nombre d'États dont la Russie
réponse avec la page je suis en train de
vous couper parce que nous avons des
obligations publicitaires comme on dit
merci beaucoup Jean-Noël Barraud d'avoir
été avec nous merci